une dégradation de l'ambiance de travail
et des relations compliquées avec le
proviseur
voilà ce que dénonce et bien 25 des 30
deux enseignants qui oeuvre ici au
collège de sombernon
en juin dernier ils ont d'ailleurs
envoyé un courrier au rectorat pour lui
demander de régler les problèmes
oui mais voilà depuis plusieurs mois et
bien le conflit s'enlise et l'ambiance
se dégrade en réponse au courrier le
rectorat déclenché une enquête
administrative
résultat des sanctions sont envisagées
contre deux professeurs une pétition de
protestation est alors lancée sur
internet et recueille plus de 3000
signatures soit trois fois la population
de sombernon
tout le monde semble dépassée même les
syndicats nous ce qu'on regrette c'est
que les collègues étaient obligés d'en
arriver à la pétition et on se dit qu'en
prenant les choses beaucoup plus en
amont
l'administration ait pu gérer la
situation et éviter aux collègues
d'avoir recours à une pétition dans un
communiqué le rectorat précise qu'aucune
sanction n'a été prononcée et que la
campagne de désinformation diffusés sur
les réseaux sociaux participent à la
dégradation de la situation
la rectrice doit également annoncer ce
soir la nomination d'un principal
adjoint et espère ainsi ramener un
climat plus serein au sein de
l'établissement